the ancient you with profits book of a
time when everybody would flourish
together that the wolf would lie down
with the lamb that that war would be
obliterated from the world that raw
aggression would finally be repudiated
but it's taking the damn long time that
we're still not there the God that says
in chapter 4 verse 34 tells the husband
you have tried to beat your woman is the
same God after we are beaten and bruised
that you paid to come from stem cell
research climate change is nothing but
mischief that can come from inventing
stories for that which we don't
understand freedom of conscience
equality of men women I think that the
Bible is authoritative i believe it's
infallible it is my basis for life and
conduct if you're entirely
fundamentalist in christian terms you
are accepting as in errant a book and a
tradition that is clearly the product of
human hands and hearts so many other
religions are about making a getting
into heaven we really don't care where
we're going this the tradition of the
tribe is the glad line there's the Quran
that is God that goes like this
scientists believe in evolution
scientists tell us climate change is
occurring so I'm not going to believe
what they say when you die God is not
going to ask you how you created here it
is going to ask what did you
what I created inquisitions and Crusades
and anti-semitism designer children
Bionic athletes how should we understand
our relation to the natural